I actually think that in some weird and  it is a very emotional thing about some  weird twisted up fateful way this  character who you know has searched her  whole life for purpose actually finds  her purpose and it's like this amazing  super emotional beautiful thing I don't  turn to people in their worst mistakes  [Music]  maybe you said you didn't  I feel very fortunate it's been an  incredible gift as an actor to be able  to come back to a character that says  complex is Natasha I think there's a  kind of a lot to explore there and that  is so exciting  this is the fight of our lives we are  getting the whole team Frank Oh God it's  a regular-sized man hey guys let's do  this  is that everyone you wanted more  are you crying this is my destiny  Avengers Assemble  [Applause]  [Music]  give me that you have the little one  [Music]